بعد الفرز الاوليه من الرابح ومن الخاسر
يمكن القول ان الجمهوريين اقتربوا من حسن
ماساه مساله الحصول على الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه الا ان حظوظهم في السيطره على
الغرفه الثانيه في الكونجرس اي مجلس
الشيوخ لا تزال معلقه بنتائج الانتخابات
في ثلاث ولايات هي ارينا نيفادا وجورجيا
فمن سيصل الى الرقم السحري وباوقف على اخر
تحديث لنتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه في مجلس النواب النواب ووفقا
لشبكه سناء حصل الجمهوريون حتى الان على
2009 مقاعد فيما حصد الديمقراطيون 192
نقطه وتتوقع في عمان ان يحفظ الجمهوريون
16 مقالا اضافيه
ليصل الاجمالي الى 225 مقعدا بينما سيصل
عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين الى 2050 اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ والتي لم تحسم
نهائيا بعد فقد حصد الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
في ما حصلت ديمقراطيون ثمانيه واربعين
مقلب